So there's,
there's the distribution of scores.
Now that's dismal,
dismal thing to look at.
You have to understand that why look at
this zero,
right?
The median person has not done anything
creative ever in their life with
anything on any dimension,
right?
It's really important to know that.
And then you have these horrible people
out here,
right?
They do everything.
Price's law.
Here's price's law.
This is something to hammer into your
heart.
The square root of the number of people
in a domain do 50 percent of the work.
Okay?
So let's,
let's go through that.
You have 10 employees,
three of them do,
half the work makes sense.
That's reasonable.
You have 100 employees,
10 of them do half the work.
That's a problem.
So the other 90 percent are doing the
other half who cares about them?
And you have 10,000
employees,
100 of them do half the work,
right?
So here's a.
here's a nasty little law.
As your company grows in,
competence grows exponentially and
competence grows linearly.
Got It right?
Because it with 10,
it's three who are doing half the work,
but at 10,000
it's 100 that are doing half the work,
so 9,900
of your employees are doing as much as
the best 100.
You might not even know who the best
$100,
but probably they know and maybe their
peers know too.
And so one of the things that's really
interesting when big companies start to
shake,
which means maybe they've had a bad
quarter,
two bad quarters and the stock price
starts to tip down and the people,
the hot people who have options,
they're not very happy about that and
maybe they start to announce layoffs.
All 100 people who have opportunities
leave and they're the ones who were
doing half the work.
So boy,
that puts your company in a pretty rough
situation because now you've got the
9,900
people left over who were only doing
half the work and the next time you
announce layoffs,
the next most productive hundred leave.
And so then you're left with nobody who
is productive at a massive overhead.
Payroll price's law.
You can look that up to solar price to
solar.
Price is a guy who was looking at
scientific productivity and one of the
things he found was when he was looking
at Phd students is that the median
number of publications for a phd
graduate when he did his work,
which was in the early sixties,
was one half as many,
had two,
half as many as that had three,
half as many as that had four.
It's a real step down and one of the
corollaries of that is that there's a
certain number of people who are hyper
productive and that's these people out
here and if you were graphing the
distribution,
let's say you graft,
how many people in our population of
300,
$10,000
in a savings account,
it would look very much like this.
Some of them would have some of them,
some of them would.
Most people would have no savings
whatsoever.
The median person would have no savings
whatsoever and then you go up here where
the one percent is.
They have all the money,
but the thing that you want to
understand about that one percent issue
that you always hear about is that it
applies in every single realm where
there's difference in creative
production.
Every realm,
it doesn't matter.
Number of records produced,
number of records sold,
number of compositions written.
So here's,
here's an example,
five composers produce the music that
occupies 50 percent of the classical rep
repertoire,
right?
Bach,
Beethoven,
Brahms,
Tchaikovsky,
Mozart.
That's right,
those five.
Okay,
so here's something cool.
So you take all the music.
Those people wrote five percent of the
music,
all those people wrote occupies 50
percent of the music that have their
writing that's played.
So not only do,
almost all of the composers never get
allison,
but even among the composers do get a
list and almost none of their music ever
gets played.
So.
So then that's it.
That's it.
Another example of this price's law
scaling.
So when it applies to all sorts of
things,
like number of hockey goal scored,
who's also a distributed this way,
number of basketball,
basketball basketball's successfully put
through the who follows the same
distribution,
uh,
size of cities follows the same
distribution.
It's a weird,
it's a weird law and you can think about
it in part.
Why does this happen while,
imagine what happens when you play
monopoly?
What happens?
Everybody has the same amount of money
to begin with,
right?
So then you start playing.
It's basically a random game while some
people start to wind a bit,
some people start to lose a bit.
And then if you win probability that
you'll keep winning starts to increase.
And if you lose your vulnerability
increases as you lose.
And then maybe you've got,
say six people playing monopoly,
soon.
One person has zero.
What happens when they have zero?
They're out of the game.
So zero is a weird number because when
you hit zero,
you're out of the game.
So,
so then if you keep playing,
people start to stack up at zero,
right?
What happens at the end of the game?
One person has all the property and all
the money and everyone else has none,
right?
That,
that's what happens if you play an
iterated trading game to its final
conclusion,
and that's part of the law in a sense
that's underlying this kind of
distribution.
So it's really,
it's,
it's not a consequence necessarily of
structural inequality.
It's built into the system at a deeper
level than that.
So you know,
people talk about all the time about how
unfair it is that the one percent of the
population has the vast amount of the
money and one percent of the one percent
has most of that money and one percent
of the,
one percent of the one percent has most
of that money.
But it is a,
it's a,
it's an inevitable conclusion of
iterated trading games.
And we don't know how to fight it.
We don't know how to take from the
people who have and move it to the
bottom without instantly moving back up
to the top.
Different people maybe,
but still back up to the top because
even the one percent churns a lot.
Like I think you have a 10 percent
chance,
if I remember correctly,
you have a 10 percent chance of being in
the top one percent for at least one
year of your life and a 40 percent
chance of being in the top 10 percent
for at least one year in your life.
That's in Canada and the US,
it's less so in Europe,
so there's a fair bit of churning at the
top end.
It's not the same people all the time.
We will have the money,
but it is a tiny fraction of the people
all the time who have all the money.